comment ça va vous allez bien
aujourd'hui je vous parle pas
aujourd'hui de téléphone apprend comment
parler bien qu'ici on est le chien au
mileu milices pro d'ailleurs j'ai déjà
fait le test
il ya quelques temps si vous l'avez pas
vu je ne m'étale et loire parce que
c'est un excellent smartphone que les 10
le me disent pro non là je vous parle de
tout autre chose je vous parle la
nouvelle surcouche de xiaomi c'est me
why 12012 qui va commencer à être
déployés un peu partout dans le monde et
qui va finir par arriver tout doucement
en france et sur beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de modèles donc ça
c'est une excellente nouvelle mais ce
qui m'intéresse moi là dessus c'est
vraiment de voir comment est-ce que
xiaot me met à jour sa surcouche
quelles sont les nouveautés qu'est ce
qu'ils proposent que c'est intéressant
parce que au delà du côté smartphones le
hardware qui est vraiment bien très
puissant très cool et compagnie ce qui
est extrêmement important c'est
l'expérience utilisateur qu'on va avoir
autour de la partie logicielle avec me
wade
mais avant toute chose que je vous
invite à faire si vous l'avez pas déjà
fait c'est à vous abonner
vous venez cliquer juste en dessous ici
vous vous abonnez vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous saurez tout des cas
une nouvelle vidéo qui arrivera parce
que des navy damman je vous parle de
smartphones là je vous parle de
surcouche joue venant aussi à des mondes
connectés d'ordinateurs des tablettes
plein de choses je mène avec moi partout
dès que c'est possible on se balade de
tous les côtés on regarde ce qui se
passe et y aussi à des conseils des
astuces pour mieux vivre sa vie
numérique et savoir notamment comment
bien vivre avec son smartphone en
harmonie avec lui allez-y abonnez-vous
comme ça vous serez tout bon wagon se
concentrait sur me wade vous il ya pas
mal de nouveautés et ya surtout un gros
travail qui a été fait en termes
d'expérience utilisateur et c'est ce qui
est plus important
la première chose qu'on vient voir pas
si vous en rendez compte que le fond
d'écran elle entend déjà les temps je le
rallume
et là on se fait un super zoom sur mars
c'est ce qu'ils appellent le super
wallpaper alors vous avez la terre que
j'ai pas réussi à installer sur une
version bêta donc c'était pour ça que ça
marche pas vous voyez j'ai un petit
message ne sait pas lire le chinois donc
je n'ai pas compris mais avec la planète
rouge ça marche c'est vraiment hypra
cool en plusieurs temps et lorsque vous
vous les voyez vous naviguez ça bouge
il ya un côté très dynamique ça c'est
vachement sympa ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point ça se situe par
an lorsque vous descendez en haut à
gauche vous avez vos notifications bon
sens un manque la cible
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là parce que
l'écran est scindé en deux parties si
vous descendez en haut à droite vous
avez ici
le centre de contrôle et ça c'est une
vraie grosse
nouveauté en tout cas on se rapproche un
peu de l'esprit d'un os de ce que nous
propose apple là dessus avec quatre gros
points on voit qu'ils sont essentiels
les données lorsque vous gagnez votre
carte sim ce qui n'est pas mon cas ici
le wifi le bluetooth et le flash et voix
vous ouvrez et vous avez plein de
petites icônes votre mode avion aux
économies d'énergie vous pouvez
enregistrer votre écran il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités et
surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est que
vous pouvez venir en rajouter vous venez
vous cliquez juste là et vous en avez
d'autres qui vont située juste ici
pouvait venir rajouter pour venir en
supprimer vous le personnaliser comme
vous voulez pour une meilleure
expérience ça pour moi c'est un des
éléments extrêmement importants et on le
voit un c'est le côté vraiment
expérience utilisateur et le côté
confort visionnage
il ya un autre point qui a été mis en
place il faut venir est activée dans les
paramètres je vous montrais c'est le
tiroir d'applications ça c'est vraiment
une grosse grosse grosse nouveauté qu'on
n'avait pas avant sur me wade
vous y retrouvez toute votre liste
d'applications mais au-dessous de la
voir différentes applis qui apparaissent
là et vous avez même des onglets vous
avez les api de communication
divertissement photographie outils vous
avez ensuite tous les paramètres de
votre tiroir d'applications qui viennent
nous sourire là c'est donc la suggestion
d'application que vous avez on pouvait
venir désactiver si vous ne les voulez
pas par exemple voyez là vous n'avez
plus la sous gestion d'applications vous
la remettez vous l'avez ça sert vraiment
bientôt mis les villas il ya plein de
personnes qui ont les smartphones de
chez omega qui manquait le tireur
d'applications là vous l'avez vous
retrouvez ces pratiques c'est vraiment
bien il vous dit ne serait-ce que ça
espèce de triptyque vous avez lavaud
notification votre centre de contrôle
votre tiroir d'applications royal
expérience allait vraiment où on va
aller va maintenant ce qui se passe du
côté des paramètres on a déjà des
repères il n'y a pas grand grande
nouveauté quand on le regarde comme ça
c'est assez clair c'est lisible ce qui
va être vraiment intéressant ça va toute
la partie affichage l'âge est un
smartphone avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui élevé ça vous
montrer ça vous explique le taux
d'actualisation à vous voyez la
différence entre le 90 hertz et le 60
hertz donc beaucoup plus fluide le
schéma de couleurs pouvant venir
paramétrer son écran est automatique
saturé qu original et là vous pouvez
aller même beaucoup plus loin à venir
choisir entre du dci p3 du srgb venir
régler directement vos couleurs
il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de possibilités le mode anti
sentiment que venus activé et même là ça
vous montre garder
lorsqu'il est normal vous baissez la
lumière des smartphones vous auriez pas
content à l'onu mais c'est ça que vous
avez comme résultat ça vous fait des
petites bandes qui bouge en fait ils
viennent créer de la fatigue oculaire
vous activez le mode anti sentiments et
ça ça disparaît le mode sombre ça s'est
vraiment bien aussi vous pouvez venir
activée
désactivé en fonction de vos besoins de
vos usages et pour maintenir le
planifier vous dire maintient le mode
selon moi je vais me mettre le soir
valeo 2 mai de 19h à 7h du matin dès que
la lumière baisse un peu on se met le
mode sombre en plus comme on l'est aussi
sur un écran oled un pixel loire est un
pixel est à n'en convient économiser et
voyez ce qui est ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est la mise en page et
c'est beaucoup plus lisible
l'affichage plein écran à aucune
allégation part je reste ou pas pour
balaj et de la navigation par gestes ça
fonctionne ça on connaît aussi y'a pas
grosse nouveauté là dessus son et
vibrations voyais on a vraiment les
quatre quarts et en os sur ce qu'on va
utiliser le plus sonnerie alarme
notification événement c'est très
efficace
on va tout de suite où on en est l'écran
d'accueil ou à venir activer/désactiver
notamment et bien le tiroir
d'applications voyez là il n'est pas
activé là il est activé clac clac oui ok
je t'ai active mot de passe sécurité
protection de la vie privée ça c'est
vraiment intéressant protection de la
vie privée
il ya beaucoup de choses à me régler
actions sensibles gérer les applications
qui demande d'autorisation sensible
accès la localisation en cours accès aux
modifications des contacts accès aux
modifications de l'historique des appels
enregistrement audio en cours accès aux
stockages vous pouvez donc être notifié
dès qu'une application va venir utiliser
votre localisation par exemple si je
m'active et mon appareil photo nikon qui
m'a dit que mon appareil photo est
ouverte je vais la retrouver la up
je clique autorisation actuellement
utilisés pour l'appareil photo et si je
veux je peux le faire mais comme ça moi
y'a plus problème est que c'est ce qui
se passe en tâche de fond avec toutes
les autorisations qui sont liées à mes
applications dans les actions spéciales
est aussi un truc qui est vraiment bien
c'est géré l'identifiant virtuel ça vous
permet lorsque vous allez sur des sites
vous n'êtes pas réellement sûr devoir
donner vos informations de créer un
identifiant virtuel donc vous ne donnez
pas vos informations mais vous pouvez
quand même d'avoir accès aux services du
site il y aussi différentes fonctions
spéciales qui sont pas mal
jetant mes paramètres je viens monter
comme ça et là j'aime petite icône en
haut à droite et je peux venir à poser
ici ça permet d'avoir une toute petite
fenêtre dans lequel je retrouverais ici
voyez mes paramètres je peux venir
naviguer ouvrir autre chose et garder ça
par exemple en surimpression peux me la
remettre dans le coin en haut ça me
permet d'avoir une petite appli ouverte
sur une autre fenêtre pour garder un
petit coup d'oeil si par exemple vous
achetez pas moi sur douve whatsapp skype
ou compagnie s'est relativement pratique
vous revenez vous montez vous le fermer
un autre point est cool c'est au niveau
de la batterie de la performance vous
voyez effectivement ouvertes au niveau
de votre batterie vous avez le mode
économie hors batterie vous avez le mode
économie hors batterie ultra ça vous
donne jusqu'à 150 mineurs en plus bon
alors vous
oubliez pas mal de fonctionnalités qui
ne vont plus fonctionner mais en tout
cas vous pourrez aller beaucoup plus
loin pour recevoir des appels et des sms
vous avez aussi une analyse de votre
batterie vous pouvez désactiver des
choses vous voyez par exemple la
désactiver le gps désactiver les
commentaires haptique ne pas réveiller
l'écran par notification il pas mal de
petites choses qui permettront de venir
gagner en autonomie lorsque vous êtes
vraiment à court de batterie
là vous ajouter 12 minutes en tout il
faut maintenir planifier une marche
arrêt de l'appareil vous dit parlant que
votre smartphone vous voulez le
réveiller le matin à 7h vous réveillez
votre smartphone up l'horloge sonne vous
l'éteignez le soir vous programmez sage
qu'on soit vraiment bien en termes de
questions de bien-être digital c'est
vraiment bien il ya un très gros focus
qui était fait également au niveau de
tout ce qui va être animations et
lorsque vous voulez fermer une
application voyez vos tirs et paf ça
explose en feu d'artifice c'est pas mal
c'est rigolo
d'un point de vue global xiaomi a bien
bossé va plus loin au niveau de
l'expérience utilisateur c'est beaucoup
plus graphique c'est beaucoup moins
austère c'est beaucoup plus
compréhensible fait d'avoir un centre de
notifications ça s'est vraiment bien
autre nouveauté qui est extrêmement
important à bien ce tiroir
d'applications je trouve ça vraiment
bien le fait de le classer par anglais
on l'avait si d'autres constructeurs
mais la pourpre on retrouve et c'est
aussi un point qui est extrêmement fort
le gros focus était fait au niveau une
fois de plus des animations et je trouve
que schumi a vraiment bien bossé va plus
loin et continue d'asseoir une position
parce que ce qui est intéressant c'est
pour moi que sur les doigts plus voir
entamer technologie leur slogan c'est
innovation for everyone l'innovation
pour tout le monde
il était un peu en dessous au niveau de
leurs surcouches là il remonte encore
d'un cran ça augmente l'expérience
personnellement je suis conquise ça
marche bien c'est pour moi un joli pause
blanche et au mit à vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous utilisez me why est ce que vous
pourriez être tenté par me wade 12 et si
c'est le cas et bien vous invite à
suivre tout ça sur le site de chiens au
mieux comme ça vous serez à quel moment
me wade 12 va être déployé sur vos
smartphones et croyez moi il ya une très
grande liste de smartphones j'ai vu sur
frandroid pour les jeter un petit coup
d'oeil
ils vous ont dit et la liste de tous les
smartphones et je pense que ça va être
vraiment cool a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous avez un
smartphone de chez tommy est ce que vous
pourriez est tenté par me wade 12
et si vous n'avez pas un smartphone de
schumi était sa cause de l'interface
graphique que vous trouviez pas terrible
et est ce que le fait de voir me wade 12
comme ça ça pourrait vous tenter oui ou
non d'une telle marque et tout ça bien
évidemment rubin kazan où se trouve
extrêmement rapidement
au quotidien par les tec moore avait des
combines plein d'amour at any ciao
[Musique]
vous